i think
the outcome of that is we're going to
question
really how we think of you know
the vulnerabilities you know you know to
our
society that exist in a cyber sense or
in a digital sense
versus in a physical sense because you
know in a lot of ways i think we
we tend to have this view and when i say
we
here i'm thinking loosely the
intelligence community
we have this view that if i find a
problem
i take note of it i don't do anything
though because it gives me an
opportunity to continue to observe
and this is this is what i think is
probably the most egregious
it is as if um
you notice uh in your picket you know
and
when i say a picket you know in your in
your security you notice
that somebody has gone missing
and there's a gap in your security and
you want to watch to see who comes in
rather than saying
oh my god there's a gap in our security
we better cover that up
this is so you know thoughts on and it's
oh i'm sure you've run into this idea oh
i've probably been part of that problem
in some ways because again it's there's
a couple of things on this one
and it's actually a really really good
point perfect perfect way of putting it
nsa came out
a couple of weeks couple of months ago
and said hey we found vulnerabilities in
this and we're going to tell everybody
about it
the cynics among us were like well you
guys have probably known about this for
the last 10 years
and oh unfortunately now somebody else
says cotton dancing just going to get
ahead of the news
and be nice people because let's face it
that probably is reality because
we find so many bugs and issues in
systems and quite honestly there is an
ethical conversation to happen
which is let's say i find a
vulnerability in and we'll talk about
these in a minute i found a
vulnerability
in a phone i can go to apple and say hey
i've got a vulnerability apple writes me
a check out or i go to bug crowd or hack
one
they write me a check out and i go off
on my merry way
i can also take that vulnerability go to
the us intelligence community and say
hey
i've given you another opportunity to
keep an eye on things because
potentially could save lives
there is that disgust now the problems
if i do that
the community at large 330 million
people running around with these blasted
phones don't get the benefit of getting
better coverage flipside is i hopefully
protect a bunch of folks that are going
in situation or into theater
that otherwise would have compromised
the communication for it's a nasty
balance
and i think the micro thing was probably
one i mean
another example on this one fbi perfect
example fbi based in taran said
we need access we need to be able to
crack mobile phones
a lot of us in the industry were like
well go down go go ask the guys down the
road
from uh in the you know on the east
coast but they can't do that or even if
they can those agencies aren't going to
tip their hand
because you know darn well as soon as
you tell the fbi that this is on there
is going to end up in court at which
point we lose
our advantage and so they end up having
to go over to obviously israel and get
it done that way and it's just
it's frustrating as all heck because
it's like
what do i want do i want to protect the
masses by telling them and helping
protect them or do i want to protect the
masses
by still being able to pull in
intelligence and information because
people don't realize how far
into their systems we actually are yeah
so i
you know i think that i mean this is
really getting to the crux of the
of the the of the problem and that is is
data security
you know and data being the the the oil
of the 21st century the thing that
drives artificial intelligence and big
data and machine learning and and all of
that
is that the thing that we should be
protecting
or do should we protect our prerogative
when it comes to having
access to other data so you know
the this is a classic military problem
do i
focus on the offense or do i focus on
the defense you know my
i've come to the conclusion that if we
don't focus on the defense in the united
states and by the way i think
the chinese and the russians have
figured this out
which is why the russians you know
basically figured out
that hey we need to be able to
disconnect from the global internet and
the chinese built a great firewall
we haven't figured this out and and i
think the authoritarians having to
control their society were the first
ones to recognize
that if we don't control this if we
don't as clinton said
nail jello to the wall which he said
they couldn't do and they clearly have
done
then we're going to be in big trouble in
terms of controlling our population so
it's really about understanding where
the 21st century is going in terms of
what is the biggest threat to your
society i think that's where we've
completely lost the bubble
and you know preserving our ability to
look into other systems
is not as important as protecting
the ability for or preventing the
ability of
other outside state actors of let's see
looking into
our system i think that's that's the key
idea here if you go back to for example
and i'm gonna i'm to go into a little
bit of
cold war deterrence theory here yeah
an air force mathematician a guy named
lieutenant general glenn clinton good
book
good monograph that he wrote called
thinking about defense and what
what he found was that in
1963 it would cost 28 billion dollars to
protect 70
of them of america from a nuclear attack
to create a defensive umbrella
but to protect 90 of the population
would cost six times that
the other thing that he found was that
for every dollar that this
that the soviet union added to their
icbm force
we would have to spend six dollars in
the in in defense
and so it was economically infeasible
and so i think
that's where mutually assured
destruction came from this is where this
idea came from
we're going to focus on growing our
economy our science and technology
and we're just going to tell the the the
soviet union if you do anything it's
all-out war
and so it was this deterrence theory
that kind of was our our main
theory uh of the victory in the cold war
but i think today in the 21st century
where
having your data is such an important
advantage
for artificial intelligence and and in
growing the
both the economy and your ability to
control populations
that the reverse is true you know we're
spending 800 billion dollars a year on
defense
and we ought to be spending it on
protecting
the data of our citizens and i think
that's where
i mean you're you're on the front lines
of that i mean would you would you
do you think do you agree with that
because you know that's where
that's the conclusion i've come to uh
it's it's hard to disagree with it
because
you hit two of the major ones obviously
they are china's got the great firewall
and they have a huge force
level leveled against us i mean
absolutely in the digital world
they have a massive force level against
us i mean i don't know what the exact
ratios are but we're outnumbered quite
considerably
you look up to your point what russia
has done with the ability to disconnect
but then you take you come back to some
of our friends you look at what a couple
of
countries in the nordic world have done
they have put protections around their
basically borders and they put
protections around their citizens
you look at what israel has done israel
knows every single year is going to get
hit by up israel
and also all the countries around it are
doing everything on the physical
and the digital world to do everything
they can they have an entire section of
that team
looking at protecting their internal
citizen their borders
we don't have that it's it's basically
all it's you know
we're all for ourselves at this point in
time it's it's the mentality is
basically it's like okay you got your
second amendment you got your going good
luck
by the way the second amendment is now
you've got your computer good luck
that's it you know i mean that's and and
that's not
going to work